hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen bio ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ich war gerade joggen und
habe mir gedacht ich nehme danach dieses
video auf und ja jetzt das ist heute
schon abend ich habe meinen bademantel
an und danach zu mir kommen drehen wir
heute doch einfach video im bademantel
habe ich schon ewig nicht mehr gemacht
irgendwann habe ich das schon mal
gemacht das weiß ich aber schon ganz
lange nicht mehr ja und es ist halt
einfach wieder mehr zeit und ihr müsst
mich auch nicht die ganze zeit im video
mit bademantel ertragen sondern nur die
hälfte weil wir den anderen part morgen
drehen jetzt wollen wir eben ein
smartphone ich hatte nämlich mal die
idee ich habe ja schon mal eure
lieblings produkte von amazon getestet
das ist jetzt ungefähr schon ja her dann
dachte ich mir bestelle ich euch doch
einfach mal sachen ich muss fairerweise
sagen kelly hat so eine art video auch
schon vor mir gemacht also wenns euch
immer ein ihr könnt euch bei mir also
sachen wünschen die ihr euch selber noch
nie gestellt habt aber gerne haben würde
und ich bestellen für euch teste die und
schenkt ihr euch dann ich habe gestern
eine installateure gepostet ja die
resonanz war riesig also ich habe
bestimmt über 1000 wünsche bekommen ihr
gehen das eine mal ganz spontan eben
durch so wir haben hier alle ansehen da
muss ich einfach direkt erst mit dem
kopf schütteln jonas ems wünscht sich
airport wie 94 50 apps filme also wir
haben hier wirklich jede menge wünsche
weil da denke ich mir ja ein bisschen
teuer für nächsten part folgt mir auf
jeden fall bei ins oder hat sich alex
wie dann könnt ihr euch auch was
wünschen wir war es nur unfassbar
wichtig dass es ausgefallen ist erst
fünf ist halt nicht so ausgefallen ist
halt nicht so spannend zum testen dann
aber ich habe vieles bestellt und teilt
es jetzt angekommen das checken jetzt
mal aus winter viel spaß dabei es sind
keine iphones irgendwelche tablets
bildschirme fernseher oder so dass
planung finde ich jetzt nicht so lustig
und ich will ja danach und
privatinsolvenz anmelden bevor wir
allerdings anfangen und sich leicht hier
fast nackt sitze haben wir hier noch die
neuen shops kopfhörer mit denen ich
gerade joggen war die sind auch der
sponsor des heutigen videos die schauen
uns macht genauer leute ich hab von
schocks die neuen open run pro
zugeschickt bekommen ich habe mir die in
der farbe blau ausgesucht sie sind jetzt
auf jeden fall neu herausgekommen und
ihr seht schon das sind nicht so
typische kopfhörer wie ich sie
eigentlich rocker aber falls sie aktiv
meine installation schaut dann könnt ihr
sehen dass ich oft joggen gehe und
natürlich meistens mit musik auf den
ohren hier kann man jetzt sehen die
können gar nicht runterfallen das ist
schon mal gut und ihr könnt sehen dieses
offene ohr design erlaubt es euch ganz
einfach podcast musik was auch immer zu
hören und gleichzeitig auch noch auf
straßenverkehr überholende fahrradfahrer
oder was auch immer konzentrieren zu
können integriert ist die schocks turbo
technologie für vorsicht alliteration
verbessere hatte besser eine unfassbare
laufzeit von bis zu zehn stunden für
musik und anrufe geil ist auch wenn ihr
mann vergessen habe die dinge aufzuladen
könnt ihr in fünf minuten eine
schnellladung durchführen und habe dann
tatsächlich eineinhalb stunden hördauer
außerdem es in den hedgefonds ein duales
mikrofon mit geräuschunterdrückung
integriert und sie sind absolut
wasserdicht also check in war den link
in der beschreibung aus mit alex wie
gibt es 10 euro rabatt schaut euch die
kopfhörer an vielleicht ist das ja was
für euch vor allem wenn ich viel sport
macht und wir machen jetzt weiter mit
dem video erstes paket glaube hier sind
drei sachen drin im nächsten tag bin ich
auch machen würde wäre ich auch gern bei
anderen plattformen bestellen das bin
ich einfach mal gespannt was ihr
geliefert wurde und ja ich teste das
heißt und dann schenke ich versprochen
also an alle die im video drankommen
jetzt sind wir schon mal bei instagram
eure adresse schicken dann würde ich
sagen fangen wir einfach mal an mit dem
ersten produkt und ich bin dann hier
immer ein wer sich das bestellt hat und
was die person dazu geschrieben hat
falls sie etwas dazu geschrieben hat und
ich sage einfach mal meine meinung dazu
hab sowas noch ganz wichtig ist weiß
nicht was kommen weil ich es nicht
selber geordnet habe das hat jemand für
mich gemacht deswegen bin ich unsere
spannte eigentlich was denn so auf ihrer
wunschliste steht was ist das denn das
sieht ja aus ist ja verkrüppelt es ein
horn oder alter guck mal leute schaut
euch das mal an was macht man damit ja
das ist eine verdammt gute frage ist es
einfach nur zierde oder was soll das
sein also ich kann mir ja fast nicht
vorstellen dass das einfach nur deko
sein soll weil dafür wäre es eigentlich
zu langweilig und hätte es nicht hinein
geschafft aber was man damit machen soll
weiß ich nicht ich würde sagen wir
gucken einfach mal kurz nach jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt was ist das vielleicht
wissen dass viele von euch auch schon
mittlerweile wir müssen mal kurz was
holen ich hoffe ich bin jetzt nicht so
der weintrinker aber ich habe eigentlich
meistens eine weinflasche hier und
soweit ich das jetzt richtig gesehen
habt kann man diese weinflasche dem
einhorn oral 1 auf jeden fall so und
dann dient das als wein halterung ich
weiß jetzt nicht was ich davon halten
soll ob mir das jetzt so gefällt weil
dieses ding wirkt auch ein bisschen
bülow aber es ist ja schlussendlich auch
nicht für mich also wenn ich das jetzt
mit einem fazit abschließen muss würde
ich sagen an sich wenn man ein lustiger
typ ist kann man sich sowas auf jeden
fall in die wohnung stellen okay leute
ich hab die auftraggeberin gefunden und
zwar ist es die michelle auf jeden fall
hat mir die michelle 22 jahre
geschrieben hey liebe
ups das stimmt gar nicht die hat mir
einfach nur den link dazu geschickt dass
mit den ich liebe deine videos über
alles war vom fünften juli 2017 also
michelle ist schon lange dabei deswegen
michael ich hoffe du wirst glücklich mit
diesem einhorn und wirst jetzt immer
wenn nur wein trinkt an mich denken und
dann schicke ich dir natürlich dieses
prachtexemplar mit einer leckeren
weinflasche die ich extra noch für dich
holen werde zu ist doch einfach cool
oder das war doch schon mal super jetzt
schauen wir mal was soll ja noch zu
bekommen
ja ja ja super also so was wollte ich
doch wirklich schon immer mal haben ein
kissen mit augen also es ist einmal ein
augen kissen muss ich dann qualitativ in
ordnung kann man auch super mit in die
schule nehmen und wenn euch dann halt
müde ist könnt ihr euch einfach einlegen
dafür ist das wahrscheinlich gemacht
hast das für sachen gibt weiß gar nicht
ob ich das so zeigen ab doch schon oder
ja kann ich jetzt nicht so viel testen
außer mich vielleicht heute nacht einmal
drauflegen aber schauen wir hier der
auftraggeber ist oder eventuell auch die
auftraggeberin wobei das glaube ich
nicht keine ahnung altern fernglas oder
nein es ist ein aha es ist ein
nachtsichtgerät m2 nightwish im alter
das ist ja geil so was habe ich noch nie
getestet und ich habe mich immer gefragt
zu nieren solche dinger weil manche
menschen können ja nachts nicht so gut
sehen ich habe auch manchmal das gefühl
dass wir nicht nachts auto fahre dass
ich halt einfach nicht so gut sehen kann
wie tagsüber wobei das wahrscheinlich
auch normal ist aber das ist eigentlich
ganz geil weil das kann ich heute nacht
mal testen weil wenn es dunkel ist gehen
wir einfach mal raus und schauen wie das
so ist bei ist wahrscheinlich auch schon
ganz ganz dunkel sein muss dafür so
nachtsichtgeräte die sind wahrscheinlich
auch gar nicht mal so günstig naja ich
muss es aufladen das liebe ich ja leute
gebt euch mal dass das muss überall so
sein ich hasse ist ja wenn man irgendwas
bestellt und dann einfach keine batterie
mittlerweile haben wir eine bayer ist
kann man einstellen hier englisch
deutsch oder französisch und jetzt habe
ich hier ein bildschirm dem ich jetzt
gerade euch sehe also oder quasi meine
kamera sehe man jetzt kann ich euch das
mal zeigen erzählt ihr nämlich seht ihr
mich haye ist voll aufgeladen und damit
gehen wir heute nacht nach hause
schreibt herr alex ich will schon immer
so etwas bekommen ich sende dir sofort
einen link es wäre so nett wenn du es
kaufen könnte ist für mich und dann habe
ich ihm einfach gekauft hin ich hoffe du
freust dich auf den 80 gerätes kleidern
mir gefällt das so gut dann behalte ich
es meinen spaß natürlich nicht später so
leute wir haben es gerade 24 uhr ist es
stockdunkel draußen das ding ist draußen
ist es doch nicht stiftung wird überall
sind halt laterne und meine kamera sieht
selbst verfasst deswegen muss ich es mal
ganz dunkel waren und das geht jetzt
gerade in mir drin aber schaut man hier
elefant main nach die wurden anscheinend
mit diesen dingen gefilmt das kann ja
schon fast nicht glauben testen was
einfach mal aus und schauen ob der tim
sich da auch etwas freuen kann licht im
flur aus der scheiße jetzt nicht mehr
gucken wo mieter ist dann geht's an und
wir machen hier schnell mal aus leute
ich teste das jetzt mal eben wo ihr leut
ich musste noch ein bisschen in den
einstellungen drehen jetzt schaut mal
wir sind gerade bei mir drin es ist
stockdunkel und jetzt haben wir hier
tageslicht modus und aha da kann man
doch was erkennen dahin ist jetzt mein
fernsehen wenn ich jetzt hier untergehe
kann man tatsächlich komplett im dunkeln
ihr meine fürs zu sehen scheint gut zu
funktionieren
ich muss wirklich sagen sollen ding ist
schon geil vor allem wenn man irgendwie
kämpfen geht oder auf abenteuerreise mit
seinen freunden eher lohnt sich so was
muss ich tat sich mal überlegen ob ich
mir nicht außerdem zulege und wir
schauen jetzt was ihr noch so haben
wollte und ich habe übrigens waren auch
für meinen zweit kann algenfilm
abonnieren jaich neuen tag der staat und
die neue ware für euch hinein gekommen
und ich hoffe euch jetzt mal also
passiert wieder ganz lustig oder ganz
kurz vor wegen erdrutschen kissen so
lässt sich das noch nie gestellt hat und
zwar ist es hier kommen dann ist der hat
sich das image wünsch verletzt das
kissen soll sehr bequem seien völlig 077
busen kissen adresse da viel spaß damit
haben wir einfach mal hier mit an das
ist eine
studentische taschentuch oder duell mit
tisch und was ich noch sagen solche
leute wenn ihr macht bei mir bestellt
dann ist es auch richtig cool wenn ihr
den text beschreibt und das ist glaube
ich auch die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich
das dann für euch kaufen immer es stinkt
das ist in das lotterie
made in china hätte ich gehe davon aus
ist ein team das mit klopapier oder mit
taschentüchern zu tun aber irgendwie
muss man hier fest machen auf jeden fall
stinkt das wie die hölle dieses ding ja
okay es ist so wie ich gedacht habe man
muss tatsächlich so einem taschentuch
box kaufen und die da hinten rein legen
und dann kann man das hier vorne raus
sind aber ich glaube wir haben so was
hier im büro des symbolischen dem
fremden also die hat das ja wenigstens
auch noch mit liefern können wir
probieren das jetzt einfach mal genau
ist kann man hier dann hält sich das nun
fest und jetzt kann man aus der nach wie
vor diesen prämie einfach seine taschen
zu ziehen man kann auch schon mal schon
das nächste mit drauf ich verstehe
lustige idee ich weiß jetzt nicht ob ich
so was irgendwie also ich glaube für
mich persönlich wäre es jetzt nicht ich
würde mir so was sehen die moment steigt
hier haben was du auch die kinder
bestellt referee taschentuch halter viel
spaß damit muss einmal am besten waschen
damit sie mal ruhig bist ja nur um ein
fünftel auf und dann wird das schon aber
für mich sicher das wird sicherlich
werde einen guten platz finden bevor wir
nicht wieder los dann haben wir ihnen
zwei paket noch was anderes was ziemlich
klein ist und zwar dass hier wieder die
taschen krispin also einfach so zum
mitnehmen muss sagen fürs gießen cool
durch banken und wir schauen dass das so
kann
also nach wie vor ist schon einiges ist
halt einfach so einen großen schritt wie
kannst du nicht immer mit lasern großes
für sie habe ich angerufen wobei ich das
hier zu feiern soll aber das ist ja
schon für mich
lief gut ich glaube ich geh jetzt gleich
in der mittagspause noch meine park und
dann festnehmen wie weit die
stark ich habe schon für spies hat sich
garten bestellt gabriel ich muss sagen
danke dass du so sparsam ist alles kann
ja auch ein bisschen teurer sein weil ja
nahmen jeweils zehn euro gekostet würde
ich schaue mir ist in tiefer in die
tasche greifen und ich weiß wenn dieses
video cool ankommen dann werde ich das
öfter machen und bin auch bereit eure
sachen zu kaufen wir sehen uns wieder
kennen doch diese lehrer die sich immer
wenn etwas wichtiges gesagt wer musste
auf die ecke vom tisch gesetzt haben vom
pult vorne an aktuell bitte leute was
geht mittagspause zwar nicht ganz
geklappt aber ich bin jetzt bei meinen
eltern wir können das auch machen weil
dies im garten mein bruder herum hat am
computer spielt kombiniert
der eiertanz so ein bisschen leiden
[Musik]
fr
es wird besser aber mein fazit ist das
ding ist zu klein also große frisbees
machen mehr sind 1 deswegen ist es hier
trotzdem zu aber er wartet nicht zu viel
spaß
23 die und hoch
weiter so leute ich wollte nur sagen die
lang fürs zuschauen ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen und wir können auf jeden
fall sehr genau im zweiten part machen
deswegen sehen wir mal ins haus schreibt
mir da schreibt mit schönen text was ihr
euch wünscht und was ich mal für euch
bestellen soll und man testen da ich
freue mich drauf aber jetzt den kanal
wir sehen uns hier schon ganz bald
wieder gibt's viel haut rein